تعمل ناسا على تخطي حدود
الاستكشاف والتكنولوجيا معلنةً
أن مهمتها التالية هي أن اليعسوب الذي يحمل
اسم الطائرة بدون طيار التي ستستكشف
أكبر أقمار زحل ، تيتان ، اليعسوب ،
سيكون أول طائرة بدون طيار
قادرة على الطيران لمسافة تزيد عن مائة ميل
عبر الغلاف الجوي الكثيف لتيتان.
على عكس أي مكان آخر في
النظام الشمسي ، يمتلك تيتان جميع
المكونات الأساسية اللازمة للحياة ، ولذا
لدينا فرصة على تيتان
لمراقبة العمليات التي كانت موجودة في
الأرض المبكرة عندما بدأت الحياة في تشكيل ناسا ، وتقول ناسا إن
مهمة كهذه كانت غير واردة حتى لو لم يكن من الممكن تصورها.
قبل بضع سنوات قصيرة ،
ستساعدنا الأدوات الموجودة على متن الطائرة في
التحقيق في الكيمياء العضوية
وتقييم القابلية للسكن والبحث عن
التوقيعات الكيميائية للحياة الماضية أو حتى
الحالية ، إذا سارت الأمور على ما يرام ، فإن
اليعسوب سيطغى حول تيتان
في عام 2034 ، أنا Reid Binion
أبلغ عن